Houston quarterback CJ
Stroud won a game and he thanked Jesus
and NBC News didn't seem to like that
what does this moment mean first
foremost I just want to give all glory
and praise to my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ I mean it's been amazing what
does this moment mean I mean it's been
amazing being in this city for as short
as I've been but the love that I've got
oh wait hold on I was the supposed to be
the same clip one was how it actually
went and then the other one was how they
posted it how they edited it and posted
and they did you see they cut out
something kind of
important weird huh isn't that weird
that the media would cut out the actual
heart of this man's message which is I
want to thank my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ can't say that it's kind of weird
we're a Christian country we're
Christian
civilization not only is that a good and
true thing for him to say but it would
be very very
popular and yet the media cut it
out weird isn't
it it's so weird how Christianity
continues to be as it has been since the
Advent of our Lord and savior the most
persecuted religion ever in the in the
whole history of the world is that kind
of weird it's almost as if we wrestle
not against flesh as they do in the
football game but against principalities
and powers and spiritual wickedness in
high places in any case maybe I got to
tune into football because this guy CJ
strad he's got his head screwed on
straight even if not a single person at
NBC seems to speaking of
football the New England new head coach
has just come out and made clear the uh
Dei policies for the team I do see color
because I believe if you don't see color
you can't see racism and
whatever whatever happens black white
disabled person I've always even someone
with disabilities I always uh you know
for the most part people are like you
know don't you know when they're young
they they kind of make the spot hot
younger people know what that means but
what I would say is like no I want you
to be able to go up to those people and
really understand those people so it
goes back to whatever it is black white
yellow it really doesn't matter but it
does matter so we can try to fix a
problem that we all know we have
it really doesn't matter but it does
matter that's the kind of high high
level discourse I would expect from
apparently a leftist now in the position
of coaching the New England
Patriots I don't see I see I see color I
see color because we got to fix the
racism the racism in
football yeah finally finally the black
man is going to have a fair Shake in the
National Football League you know it's
been a long time coming but I am so
relieved that finally we're going to see
a black guy playing football you know
isn't that great wow the Civil Rights
Movement is finally flourishing we're
going to get or if if you wanted to see
color to stop the uh
racial inequality in football you would
have to introduce the first White player
into football that's not fair there are
some obviously there was uh the former
quarterback for this very team what's
that guy Brady he he was pretty popular
and uh let me think of another white
football player there's the guy who's
dating Taylor
Swift and um and that's it I think I
think that's pretty much all of
it white people the lone white
people I don't even really disagree with
this
guy in principle if his premises were
true that there were some awful racism
then he's right the only way to rectify
that problem would be to be conscious of
Race To not to not deny that people have
racial
differences what I think he's missing
what all of the libs miss when they iny
against the evil white man the source of
all the problems in the world we are
told is
that white people are the only people
who do not see color in as much as that
phrase means anything at all I don't sea
color I don't the only people for whom
that is true is white
people the only people for whom that has
been true ever in the whole history of
the world is white people this is very
clear from Modern social
science when when you ask people their
racial
Consciousness when when you ask people
hey is race is your race somewhat or
very important to you every racial group
other than white people is above 50
% Asians Hispanics for black people it's
above
70% what's the number for white people
15 white people have zero racial
Consciousness 15% I guess they don't
they really don't see color everyone
else does and everyone else has for all
of history which is how we've ended up
in a situation today where white people
are the only group that you can
discriminate against by law and
according to the mores of
Society you can also discriminate
against the Asians by law but it's still
socially unacceptable to criticize them
or to insult them white people are the
only group that you can legally
discriminate against in college
admissions for instance even after the
overturning of affirmative action all
the schools came out and said don't
worry we'll work around this we're still
going to discriminate against whitey in
the admissions but they're also the only
group that you are encouraged to
discriminate against the only group that
that you are taught in school and in the
media and in Hollywood and just
everywhere the only group that we were
told is is the cause of all the problems
in the world everyone's going to attack
this guy for this view this is the view
that most people hold ironically white
people don't really hold that view I
don't want to brag but I just received a
major
honor this comes by way of
fire very well-known organization
freedom of uh individual rights in
education
they have a list of all the cancelled
speakers this year on the right and on
the left they're virtually all
right-wingers canceled by the left but
they got a list and it turns
out I am the
champion disinvite of 2023 I was
cancelled I was disinvited from campus
speaking engagements more than anyone
else in 2023 and I consider that a great
honor I lost
a lot of opportunities to get my views
out there I lost money I
lost a really important part of what I
do which is to
but I gained a lot I gained the greatest
amount of ir from the left and I take
that as as a great badge uh some of my
fellow contestants most of these guys
are actually personal friends of mine I
think
Matt and Charlie Kirk but came in second
I think uh ilas Shapiro those guys had
and maybe Riley gains too they had two
cancellations
each I think maybe Riley only had one no
Riley had two and uh there there were
some other shoutouts there as well James
Lindsay got canceled there were a number
of them I'm really honored I'm
especially honored because I didn't even
State publicly all of the cancellations
they credit me here with three
I was actually cancelled from more
like five or six schools and I I haven't
said it publicly because I don't want to
just whine all the time believe it or
not about uh these kind of personal SLS
but also because we might be able to
beat the liberal administrations and end
up this semester on those campuses so
we're going to play it cool in any case
though thank you to fire thank you to
the leftist administrators at the
universities thank you first to the
conservative students for inviting me
thank you to the leftist administrators
for cancelling me in this ridiculous way
because I have the audacity to say crazy
things like men are not women and
there's objective truth and stuff like
that and uh for all of my fellow
contestants I look forward to sharing a
bowl of GRL with all of you in the goog
probably sooner rather than later if
things keep going the way that they
are I also want to thank Steve Maguire
who's a fellow at the American Council
of trustees and alumni for pointing out
my uh dubious distinction man what a
great clip that was now hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel and we
will catch you next time